لم تكن تتوقع الفنان الكوميديه ساره ان
تستنسخ اعمالها الكوميديه بشخصيه مماثله
في الذكاء الاصطناعي هذا ما حدث بالفعل مع
فنانين ومبدعين استخدمت اعمالهم من قبل
شركات الذكاء الاصطناعي دون تعويضهم بل
اضطر بعضهم الى ان يلاحقوا شركات الذكاء
الاصطناعيه قضائيا ابعد من ذلك تحدثت
صحيفه واشنطن في الامريكيه عن عريضه
موقعها اكثر من خمسه الاف شخص طالبت
الشركات بالحصول على موافقه رسميه قبل
استخدام اعمالهم يقول خبراء ان الامر
مرتبط بارزاق الملايين من الفنانين
والمبدعين مما اثار حفيظتهم ضد شركات مثله
اوبن اي وجوجل التي تستخدم مليارات من
المقالات والكتب والصور ومقاطع الفيديو
المحميه بقانون الملكيه الفكريه
من جانب اخر تستند الشركات الى استثناء
موجود في التشريعات المتعلقه بحقوق
الملكيه الفكريه تستخدم الاعمال بطريقه
مبتكره وليست نسخا بحسب قولها ورغم ذلك
يرى البعض ان هناك اجحافا في ان تقوم
الشركات بتطوير ادوات تساعدها على جني
المزيد من المال دون تعويض اصحابها ويبقى
السؤال عن مصير تلك الاعمال الابداعيه
البشريه في مواجهتها للذكاء الاصطناعي
والشركات القائمه عليه حيث فضل بعضهم
التفاوض مع شركات الذكاء الاصطناعي للحصول
على تعويض بينما اختار اخرون رفع دعا
وقضائيه للدفاع عن حقوقهم
فهل اصبحت الاعمال الابداعيه اليوم في خطر
من قبل الذكاء الاصطناعي وهل تحتاج
التشريعات الموضوعه لحمايه الملكيه
الفكريه الى اعاده النظر فيها
[تصفيق]